in 2011 an article was published in the
reputable Journal of Personality and
Social Psychology it was called feeling
the future experimental evidence for
anomalous retroactive influences on
cognition and effect or in other words
proof that people can see into the
future
the paper reported on nine experiments
in one participants were shown two
curtains on a computer screen and asked
to predict which one had an image behind
it the other just covered a blank wall
once the participant made their
selection the computer randomly
positioned an image behind one of the
curtains then the selected curtain was
pulled back to show either the image or
at the blank wall the images were
randomly selected from one of three
categories neutral negative or erotic if
participants selected the curtain
covering the image this was considered a
hit now with there being two curtains
and the images positioned randomly
behind one of them you would expect the
hit rate to be about 50% and that is
exactly what the researchers found at
least for negative and neutral images
however for erotic images the hit rate
was 53% does that mean that we can see
into the future is that a slight
deviation significant well to assess
significance scientists usually turn to
p-values a statistic that tells you how
likely a result at least this extreme is
if the null hypothesis is true in this
case the null hypothesis would just be
that people couldn't actually see into
the future and the 53% result was due to
Lucky guesses for this study the p-value
was 0.01 meaning there was just a 1%
chance of getting a hit rate of 53
percent or higher from simple luck
p-value is less than 0.05 are generally
considered significant and worthy of
publication but you might want to use a
higher bar before you accept that humans
can accurately perceive the future and
say invite the study's author on your
news program but hey it's your choice
after all the point O 5 threshold was
arbitrarily selected by Ronald Fisher in
a book he published in 1925 but this
raises the question how much of the
published research literature is
actually false the intuitive answer
seems to be 5% I mean if everyone's
using P less than 0.05 as our cutoff for
statistical significance you would
expect five of every hundred results to
be false positives but that
unfortunately grossly under
estimates the problem and here's why
imagine you're a researcher in a field
where there are a thousand hypotheses
currently being investigated let's
assume that 10% of them reflect true
relationships and the rest are false but
no one of course knows which are which
that's the whole point of doing the
research now assuming the experiments
are pretty well designed they should
correctly identify around say 80 of the
hundred true relationships this is known
as a statistical power of 80% so twenty
results are false negatives perhaps the
sample size was too small or the
measurements were not sensitive enough
now consider that from those 900 false
hypotheses using a p-value of 0.05 45
false hypotheses will be incorrectly
considered true as for the rest they
will be correctly identified as false
but most journals rarely published no
results they make up just 10 to 30
percent of papers depending on the field
which means that the papers that
eventually get published will include 80
true positive results 45 false positive
results and maybe 20 true negative
results nearly a third of published
results will be wrong even with the
system working normally things get even
worse if studies are underpowered and
analysis shows they typically are if
there is a higher ratio of false to true
hypotheses being tested or if the
researchers are biased all of this was
pointed out in a 2005 paper entitled why
most published research is false so
recently researchers in a number of
fields have attempted to quantify the
problem by replicating some prominent
past results the reproducibility project
repeated 100 psychology studies but
found only 36% had a statistically
significant result the second time
around and the strength of measured
relationships were on average half those
of the original studies an attempted
verification of 53 studies considered
the landmarks and the basic science of
cancer only managed to reproduce six
even working closely with the original
study's authors these results are even
worse than I just calculated the reason
for this is nicely illustrated by a 2015
study showing that eating a bar of
chocolate every day can help you lose
weight faster in this case the
participants were randomly allocated to
one of three treatment groups one went
on a low-carb diet
another went on the same low-carb
plus a one point five ounce bar of
chocolate per day and the third group
was the control instructed just to
maintain their regular eating habits at
the end of three weeks the control group
had neither lost nor gained weight
but both low-carb groups have lost an
average of five pounds per person the
group that ate chocolate however lost
weight ten percent faster than the non
chocolate eaters the finding was
statistically significant with a p-value
less than 0.05 as you might expect this
news spread like wildfire to the front
page of build the most widely circulated
daily newspaper in Europe and then to
The Daily Star the Irish Examiner -
Huffington Post and even shape magazine
unfortunately the whole thing had been
faked
kind of I mean researchers did perform
the experiment exactly as they described
but they intentionally designed it to
increase the likelihood of false
positives the sample size was incredibly
small just five people per treatment
group and for each person 18 different
measurements were tracked including
weight cholesterol sodium blood protein
levels sleep quality well-being and so
on so if weight loss didn't show a
significant difference there were plenty
of other factors that might have so the
headline could have been chocolate
lowers cholesterol or increases sleep
quality or something the the point is a
p-value is only really valid for a
single measure once you're comparing a
whole slew of variables the probability
that at least one of them gives you a
false positive goes way up and this is
known as pee hacking researchers can
make a lot of decisions about their
analysis that can decrease the p-value
for example let's say you analyze your
data and you find it nearly reaches
statistical significance so you decide
to collect just a few more data points
to be sure
then if the p-value drops below 0.05 you
stop collecting data confident that
these additional data points could only
have made the result more significant if
there were really a true relationship
there but numerical simulations show
that relationships can cross the
significance threshold by adding more
data points even though a much larger
sample would show that there really is
no relationship in fact there are a
great number of ways to increase the
likelihood of significant results like
having two dependent variables adding
more observations controlling for gender
or dropping one of three conditions
combining all three of these strategies
together increase
the likelihood of a false positive to
over 60% and that is using P less than
0.05 now if you think this is just a
problem for psychology neuroscience or
medicine consider the pentaquark an
exotic particle made up of five quarks
as opposed to the regular three for
protons or neutrons particle physics
employs particularly stringent
requirements for statistical
significance referred to as five sigma
or one chance in 3.5 million of getting
a false positive but in 2002 a japanese
experiment found evidence for the theta
plus pentaquark and in the two years
that followed eleven other independent
experiments then looked for and found
evidence of that same pentaquark with
very high levels of statistical
significance from July 2003 to may 2004
a theoretical paper on pentaquarks was
published on average every other day but
alas it was a false discovery further
experimental attempts to confirm that
theta plus pentaquark using greater
statistical power failed to find any
trace of its existence the problem was
those first scientists weren't blind to
the data they knew how the numbers were
generated and what answer they expected
to get and the way the data was cut and
analyzed or P hacked produced the false
finding now most scientists aren't P
hacking maliciously there are legitimate
decisions to be made about how to
collect analyze and report data and
these decisions impact on the
statistical significance of results for
example 29 different research groups
were given the same data and asked to
determine if dark-skinned soccer players
are more likely to be given red cards
using identical data some groups found
there was no significant effect while
others concluded dark-skinned players
were three times as likely to receive a
red card the point is that data doesn't
speak for itself it must be interpreted
looking at those results it seems that
dark-skinned players are more likely to
get red carded but certainly not three
times as likely consensus helps in this
case but for most results only one
research group provides the analysis and
therein lies the problem of incentives
scientists have huge incentives to
publish papers in fact their careers
depend on it as one scientist Brian no
SEC puts it there is no cost to getting
things wrong the cost is not getting
them published journals are far more
likely to publish results that reach
statistical significance so if a method
of data analysis results in a p-value
less than 0.05 then you're likely to go
with that method publications also more
likely if the result is novel and
unexpected this encourages researchers
to investigate more and more unlikely
hypotheses which further decreases the
ratio of true to spurious relationships
that are tested
now what about replication isn't science
meant to self-correct by having other
scientists replicate the findings of an
initial discovery in theory yes but in
practice it's more complicated like take
the precognition study from the start of
this video three researchers attempted
to replicate one of those experiments
and what did they find
well surprise surprise the hit rate they
obtained was not significantly different
from chance when they tried to publish
their findings in the same journal as
the original paper they were rejected
the reason the journal refuses to
publish replication studies so if you're
a scientist the successful strategy is
clear and don't even attempt replication
studies because few journals will
publish them and there is a very good
chance that your results won't be
statistically significant anyway in
which case instead of being able to
convince colleagues of the lack of
reproducibility of an effect you will be
accused of just not doing it right so a
far better approach is to test novel and
unexpected hypotheses and then P hack
your way to a statistically significant
result now I don't want to be too
cynical about this because over the past
10 years things have started changing
for the better
many scientists acknowledge the problems
I've outlined and are starting to take
steps to correct them there are more
large-scale replication studies
undertaken in the last 10 years plus
there's a site retraction watch
dedicated to publicizing papers that
have been withdrawn there are online
repositories for unpublished negative
results and there is a move towards
submitting hypotheses and methods for
peer review before conducting
experiments with the guarantee that
research will be published regardless of
results so long as the procedure is
followed this eliminates publication
bias promotes higher powered studies and
lessens the incentive for pee hacking
the thing I find most striking about the
reproducibility crisis in science is not
the prevalence of incorrect information
in published scientific journals after
all getting to the truth we know is hard
and mathematically not everything that
is published can be correct what gets me
is the thought that even trying our best
to figure out what's true using our most
sophisticated and rigorous mathematical
tools peer review and the standards of
practice we still get it wrong so often
so how frequently do we delude ourselves
when we're not using the scientific
method as flawed as our science may be
it is far and away more reliable than
any other way of knowing that we have
this episode of veritasium was supported
in part by these fine people on patreon
and by audible.com the leading provider
of audiobooks online with hundreds of
thousands of titles in all areas of
literature including fiction nonfiction
and periodicals audible offers a free 30
day trial to anyone who watches this
channel just go to audible.com slash
potasium so they know I sent you a book
I'd recommend it is called the invention
of nature by Andrea Wolfe which is a
biography of Alexander von Humboldt an
adventurer and naturalist who actually
inspired Darwin to board the Beagle you
can download that book or any other of
your choosing for a one-month free trial
at audible.com slash veritasium so as
always I want to thank audible for
supporting me and I really want to thank
you for watching